- We match, we match your attire.
- So, I wasn't sure
about this pink jacket,
'cuz I'm not really
always a pink girl. Right?
But when I showed up Kelly
Clarkson's dressing room,
is so bright and cheery.
- [Kelly] Vibrant.
- And vibrant and pink. I
felt I wore the right thing.
- See?
- And then I was walking out,
and I had this Kelly Clarkson mug.
- [Kelly] It's all pink.
- And it, and it all just.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- Assured me I was in the right place.
- [Kelly] Meant to be.
- It was meant to be.
- So, wait, it was nice to
see you on your podcast.
I did your show.
- Which just dropped, everybody can watch.
- Okay. They can watch now.
- They can watch now, it just dropped.
- Because some of the
things I was talking about
in the interview, I was like,
I don't know if I should talk
about this until my record
job, my record's coming soon.
So I was like, good timing.
- [Angie] Yes, you should
and you should all watch it.
'Cuz that's what it's about.
It's about what you're
willing to share, right?
Like every episode is like,
I don't know,
I made the podcast in
hopes that every episode
people can take from people's real lives.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, and have takeaways
for our own real lives.
- [Kelly] So, but it, it's
called In Real Life and I, I,
I have to say this, and I
say, I said this when I left.
- Yeah.
- When you weren't there.
- [Kelly] That was the most
enjoyable interview ever.
- That makes me so happy.
- [Kelly] No, I did.
And I honestly, it's because I
love being able to be honest.
But I also, like,
we can all tell when someone's trying to,
get a,
a catchphrase and kind,
- [Angie] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know, some kind of headline.
- That's the beauty about
having, I've had a long career,
I've had a very, thank God,
I've had a beautiful career.
I'm at a point where I don't,
I'm not, don't do anything.
- [Kelly] You don't have to chase that.
- So I'm not chasing it.
If I get a hundred thousand views,
or two million views, every
interview's different.
I don't chase that.
I really chase what is a true connection.
What can I learn from you?
- [Angie] What can my
audience learn from you?
So yeah.
So it's, the podcast has been
really beautiful in that way.
- [Kelly] It's really cool.
- The way people happy show
up, including you, thank you.
- Yeah.
- Has been, has been great, so.
- [Kelly] Okay, so Angie, you
were part of a powerful moment
for women in hip-hop.
So, the Not Tonight
collaboration with Left Eye.
- Yes.
- I loved Left Eye. Lil Kim.
- So let me, lemme paint the picture.
So, I'm like a baby.
I had rapped on maybe
one or two things ever.
I get a call that says Lil'
Kim is doing this remix
of this song she has, Not Tonight.
It's called Ladies Night.
And they wanna know if you do
a few bars at the beginning.
- I remember this.
- This you remember, right?
- Yes, yes, it's a huge record.
- [Angie] Yeah, it's a big record.
Got nominated for a Grammy.
So, I'd never been
(vocal siren sound)
- A Grammy nominated, we
performed MTV and Music Awards.
We should pull it up.
It's the dance, and the things.
No, but, so I get called and I'm a baby.
I am like, I literally sing in the song,
I'm the rookie on this All-Star team.
I was the rookie.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so they said it's
gonna be you, Missy Elliot.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Angie] Little Kim.
- [Angie] Da Brat.
Oh, look at us! And Left Eye, and then me.
- [Kelly] Look how cool y'all are.
- Yeah. I, I had no idea I
was doing way over my head.
I showed up to the (laughter)
I was just way over my
head, but it was so great.
They, they was so kind to me,
and then the record just took off.
And so, I really had
this amazing opportunity
of like, stepping into the world,
and then watching it at a high level.
- Yeah.
- [Angie] Like watching it get nominated,
getting invited to perform
at the MTV Awards and,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Everything that comes with that.
It was a really amazing experience.
And I got to do this
video, where it was like,
Queen Latifah came, and Total, and TLC,
and it was just all of these
women supporting each other.
It really was an amazing experience.
Shout out to Lil' Kim
for creating that moment,
for, for all of us.
- [Kelly] And shout out
to her too, because that,
it's so powerful
when women are lifting up other women.
- [Angie] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And, and you know, there's
been, there's been times
throughout the culture
where we see less women.
- [Chance] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
And now we're seeing so many more women.
- Yeah.
- And that makes me so happy.
- That happens in all genres of music.
- It does, right?
- In the nineties, like
women were killing it,
and then like all of a
sudden there was like.
- [Angie] Yeah.
- Where are women? For like
ever in like country like,
especially.
- [Angie] Same thing, right?
- And then yeah, and it went away,
and like now they're coming back,
it's like, yeah, it ebbs and flows.
- [Angie] I think we're here now to stay.
- Somehow men always get to stick around.
- Yeah. What is that about?
What is that about?
You speak on behalf, Chance.
- Why, Chance?
- Shout out to Lil' Kim.
(clapping and laughter)
Queen Latifah,
I'm, I'm, I, hey man.
- [Kelly] I'm just hang out over here.
Okay. So listen, you've been on the show.
Have you been on here?
- This, this is is my third time
and I know where you're
going with this already.
- [Kelly] Okay, I'm just
saying! I'm just saying.
- [Angie] I was backstage
and I saw you being very
competitive with Chance.
Like she's very competitive.
- That's how she does.
- [Angie] And see I love her.
- [Kelly] I love you too, but.
- But then we also get into this thing,
where I want to, I want to.
- Yeah.
- Let me explain what happens.
We get into this, where we play
a game, and then she loses.
(laughter)
- Ooh.
- Don't laugh, don't laugh.
Don't encourage her.
That's not what happened.
Anybody saw the last episode?
- [Kelly] I will say the last one,
you were kind of robbed, but whatever.
- I was all the way robbed.
- [Kelly] Yep, yep, yep.
But you didn't win.
So would you like (laughter)
- [Angie] Don't laugh,
don't encourage it, guys.
- Would you like another shot?
- I am ready for whatever
you want to try to do.
- [Kelly] Okay, cool.
We've got a game, honoring
50 years of hip-hop.
When we get back.
- [Angie] Just saying
something terrible to us.
- Chances are, Angie loses it y'all.
- Stay here to find out.